this program features live coverage of
an African safari and may include animal
kills and caucuses viewer discretion is
advised this program features live
coverage of an African safari it's a
wonderful Sunday and you are looking at
a lovely drawn go and now you're looking
at me I am Trish ala nice to have you on
board as always and we have Craig on
camera with us yes we do so it is
completely 100% live and interactive so
you can use the hashtag Safari live on
Twitter or of course the YouTube chat
stream to communicate with us now I have
my hand up here because the Sun is
beating down on us today
it truly is it's about 32 degrees
Celsius about 89 degrees Fahrenheit so
it is really really hot that means that
our plan for today is of course to look
in any shady spots and to look up into
the trees and maybe find some sleepy
very hot leopards of course also to
check the watering holes but I have
taken the west of the of the reserve at
the moment and we have Jimmy who will be
joining us shortly and you'll meet him
and he's taking the east will also
hopefully be joined by Lauren very soon
up in the Maasai Mara as well so lots to
be excited about today now we do know
that
Tandi has moved off into another area
and so have the lions into an area that
we can't go into but the lions move so
quickly through Juma and sort of
straight through it into the other
properties so we may be lucky and we'll
be able to see them as well all of us
are looking for patches of shade to stop
in because of this heat
so we know that the animals would
possibly be doing the same you seeing a
few birds flying around but at the
moment don't think I can hear anything
let's listen for a second
it's very quiet at the moment very quiet
but that'll change as soon as the Sun
Goes Down that will change so stay tuned
who knows what will happen so while I am
on the west or in the West I will be
looking for tracks of who koumori and
shadaloo of course with hopefully Cubs
in tow which would be awesome I think
now remember we had that skittish male
around yesterday as well now he doesn't
seem to stay in any particular area
let's try to avoid all the bits of dung
we try to avoid the bits of dung because
there may be dung beetles and other
little creatures that are in there and
if we drive straight over them it's not
very nice for them is it so maybe you
guys can tell me what you'd like to see
and what you'd expect to see today
considering the heat remember use the
hashtag Safari live and let me know if
you're requesting a Pangolin I suggest
you don't tweet
oh it seems that Jimmy is up and running
as well so why don't I send you over to
him so he can say good afternoon to you
all
good afternoon folks welcome to Juma
there in the greater Kruger National
Park and trishula good luck with that
skittish leopard and yet avoid those
dung beetles I'm Jimmy and behind camera
is Seb where these thumb and our plan
the soft noon is to try and stick in the
shade as much as possible and move
between some of the permanent water
because it's 32 degrees here this
afternoon about double the temperature
of the Mara so not too much is going to
be active while this Sun is beating down
on us you can hear there's not too much
bird calls either
and so we gonna amble through past
different water holes and see what we
can find and hopefully they we can come
up on some elephant or some other and
antelope drinking and hopefully a cat or
two so let's proceed and move on through
this heat
not too many clouds in the sky today
it's sir
Matthew I got did you say how hot was it
yeah and if it was the question it is 32
degrees in the shade and that's sorry
time what time is it yeah okay it is now
20 to 4:00 in the afternoon so their
freakin time
yes some nice shade going into so if
anything's going to be standing around
tall it starts getting active it it will
be in these areas where there's a little
bit of density and shade it just makes
it fine makes our job finding them a
little bit harder but are we gonna keep
trying to find you something through
here and in the meantime we're gonna
send you to trash Allah who has a
surprise for you on camera oh my gosh
guys I've got an ostrich this is the
first one I've seen in Juma this is
amazing
just watch it they're coming through the
thickets you should see a gap there the
second oh there's a pair of them how
cool is this
now we are exhorted in an area that's a
lot more grassy and little more a little
less bushy so this is why they're
probably in this on this side and not so
much with further down in the south Wow
so this is obviously a pear
Wow let's try and get a little bit
closer but I don't want to scare them
off what do you think Craig I reckon we
can I think we can you guys as excited
as I am I think this is quite special
so ostriches prefer this type of
landscape you can see it's quite open
and grassy
that's obviously because of their
massive size they need to be able to
move freely and if they in the bushes
and a thicket that won't be able to
happen they are stunning
giraffe go you say you've never seen
this before
a pair of ostriches right here in Juma
well I'll tell you what I haven't seen
it before not on Juma I've seen
ostriches before they call feeding hi
guys welcome to Juma is this your first
experience here and you already made it
to live TV or online TV go guys
now these are of course the largest and
heaviest birds and they have very
ancient Birds
seek truth you'd like to know if it's a
mum and the young one oh look at that
prance look at it yes yes it's a bit of
a model and you asked if this is a mum
and a young one you can tell that
there's a bit of a size difference but I
don't think this is a mum and a young
one I think this is a pair look at that
now the females tend to be slightly
browner so this doesn't look like two
males look at that pose
I always think they look like ballet
dancers they've got these stockings and
then these very extravagant tutus on
almost because the neck doesn't look
very much like a ballet dance especially
not when it's down there
now they mostly eat plant material or
vegetation so that's what this one is
going after at the moment very very cool
on car you'd like to know how tall they
are
well the male's can get up to 2 meters
tall so if I had to stand in front of
them their tower over me
I am only about one point five eight
meters tall so they were definitely
definitely tower over me Wow guys this
is so amazing to me now I saw an ostrich
not too long ago in the town very close
by here and this ostrich started to do a
bit of a dance to me and and whack his
head from side to side against his body
in the time that I was thinking what are
you doing he sprinted towards me and it
was just the fence in between us so
these guys can actually be quite
intimidating if they decide that they
don't like you
check them out just pulling little bits
of seeds from those grasses and of
course little fresh vegetation or
vegetation that's right at the bottom
well now it looks like one ostrich with
two necks absolutely stunning
so like we spoke about two meters tall
about a hundred kgs for the male's about
90 for the females oh look at that
now these guys are not designed for
flight and even though you can think
that they probably have a really big
wingspan if they're to open it up the
feathers are actually not designed for
flight or rather they've been reduced in
terms of the sort of barbs and hooks
that hold feathers together they don't
have that very much and if you've seen
an ostrich feather it's not intact like
in the same way as other birds feathers
are rigid and hard in order to get the
air to flow over them these feathers are
very very soft and they're not really
linked together by those Barb's like the
other feathers are
hello look at how brightly colored that
beak is
Wow The Silence of the bush has finally
given us something wonderful it was nice
I am so excited
I'm just going to call this in because
this is quite a rare sighting maybe some
other people would like to join us and
I'm sure why the audience would like to
join us as well so let me call this in
quickly and then we can invite some more
people on board here
good afternoon mobile stations it's
Trish from wild earth I have located a
pair of ostriches on sandy patch and
just where the junction of Audry's and
sandy patch is maybe moving about 100
meters 100 meters west well yes I think
we could have some more people on board
this is truly rare
ah so someone else has just told me that
these two have been here earlier in the
day and they've already seen them copy
they're lovely really really nice when
you see something like this sometimes
it's just really cool to just sit and
watch them because all of the things
that you read in the books are just
nothing compared to sitting and watching
them in their way that they behave
hello and welcome everybody we are here
in Juma private game reserve and we have
quite a rare sighting it's a pair of
ostriches right here in the western
section of the park isn't this beautiful
now we don't often see them here which
is why it's such an exciting moment and
they here in the short grass in the
grassland on this side Wow
now you can see that tall legs and the
long necks absolutely study look at
those big feathers and they're feeding
along quite happily on all the
vegetation as they go they've been very
good to us
absolutely beautiful
that arawa all you say that they're as
big as trees they certainly can be as
big as trees two meters tall that's what
we said see this one's starting Oh put
that Nick to good use you can scratch
all the way around now I think what
we're looking at is actually two males
when you get a side of the other one
well Karen you say they're huge they are
huge if you look at him there with us
standing with the neck up straight now
you can get a good idea of the height
there that is a tall bird very tall bird
right there we don't often get to see
that you see them in more of this
relaxed pose even that he's a little bit
stiffer the neck up held up up high
Wow
absolutely stunning now these are very
ancient birds and they are huge males to
about 100 kgs females to about 90 kgs
really really big guys now I'm saying
that these are both males because the
males are mostly black and they have bit
of white on the wings and of course a
white butt on the tail which is what
we're seeing there that's a bit dirty at
the moment
for the females it's a bit more brownie
but grayish
very cool
Barbara you'd like to know how I think
related the Penguins are to the
ostriches well of course they are both
birds so they do fetch is suppose into
the same group but they have ah how much
water do they need compared to penguins
well of course penguins need a whole lot
of water because they water dependent in
order to to eat and survive and breed
whereas cancel penguin she says you mean
ostriches how much is the requirement of
ostriches I'm not quite sure but I would
think that they would need some water we
see birds always near the dams and
things like that looking for water so I
would assume that I would need Sun but I
would check up for you definitely
now I'm gonna reposition because they're
still around you and they're moving
quite slowly and they're being very good
to us so let's do this quickly
now they are quite used to the heat and
you do see them in sort of arid areas so
they are not so much looking for shade
as much as I am are they there we go
here we've got a small gap how's that
Craig
very cool cleanly you'd like to know
what I would suppose that predators
would do if they come across these
ostriches did I hear that correctly
sorry I was just repositioning at the
same time they see they've noticed us
and they're quite still at the moment I
would suppose that they may try to hunt
these ostriches but on ostriches are
really really big and they also have
quite dangerous claws on their feet so
the extent where once read a story about
a guy who had an interaction with an
ostrich and went foul unfortunately and
the ostrich had actually ripped through
the front of his shirt and his leather
belt so that'll give you an idea of
exactly how strong and sharp those claws
of the ostrich are
look at those no blinis
now lots of them can actually gather
together but what we're seeing here is
just a pair for the moment
even though they do mostly eat
vegetation they have been known to eat
termites every now and then especially
the juveniles
ah there they go walking away the pair
head held high absolutely stunning
well thank you so much for joining us
for this and remember that if you'd like
to keep on watching you can go onto
YouTube and just type in Safari live and
you can keep on watching this completely
live there'll be these ostriches and
many many other animals so please do
so cool guys don't you think so now look
how they hold their head just above the
ground I think on average they hold
their head about 30 centimeters above
the ground so it's really easy to just
snap that now if you look at actually
the way that it just moved you could see
that if it were running and being chased
by a predator like we were asked earlier
it could easily change directions and
sort of move from side to side but I've
said this before they can be quite
intimidating and they look quite
intimidating especially if they want to
give you a bit of a display and they
start swinging their necks around it
hitting the sides of their body
there they go behind that bush let's try
and get a little bit of a better view of
them I want to make the most of this
because it's something we don't see very
often
they seem to be fairly comfortable
although they've moved up on the other
side now
there's a bit of an animal animal path
in front of us we can use that to get to
them also don't want to die
you know I just had this feeling to come
to the west today and I'm so glad that I
did okay I'm just gonna get over this
and then we will stop sorry if you see
any blurriness or pixelation we are just
having a small difficulty at the moment
so I'm just gonna stay put so we can get
good signal coming through to you guys
really huge
wow it really is quite inspiring to be
in front of them because they aren't big
let's go further along the road let's
just check with Nina if signal is all
good it said Nina if it is if we can
move off it's quite nice because you can
see their heads above the bushes just a
bit well they seem to have moved off so
I will try to keep up with them and but
in the meantime let me send you to
Lauren who has finally gotten out so
let's go up to the Maasai Mara
good afternoon we are here after all in
the Mara we just had some rambling
issues to deal with but ostriches in
Juba ostriches in June I can't believe
it I'm so happy for church Allah that is
indeed awesome
now of course my name is Lauren and on
camera I have bungee cord and today we
are at it is extremely hot and we have
managed to solve all of our
technological issues so we are indeed on
our way to investigate some lions I
don't know what lions that are yet but
we will indeed investigate a little bit
further and hopefully figure out who
they are our initial plan was to go to
the border and visit the beautiful my
brothers that is the coalition of two
brothers of cheetah however I think we
better
and the space film today the border is
very far away due to the fact that these
gremlins might come back and try to
battle with us again so we're going to
keep our plan a little bit more local
but I promise you within the next few
days I will get to these sheets of
brothers and we will be able to explore
them a little bit further so for now
lions will have to be the cave now last
night here in the Maasai Mara
we had an absolutely incredible and
torrential storm and nearly blew all of
our tents over to be honest and wow it
was incredible so I do believe the rains
are very much on their way now and this
season is started to change luckily we
were all tucked up inside together
watching a movie so it's absolutely fine
but it was an incredible storm so it's
been very quiet in the Mara Frank today
so we're gonna try and do as much
exploring and investigating as we can
for now but other than that I don't have
any real updates now I'm not sure if
Trek this morning was able to give you a
little bit more details about the
giraffe incident but he actually went
and checks
the mother nor the bad cough remain
anymore so the mother has indeed gone we
don't know where she's gone but I do
believe at some point she just will have
moved off as far as I can tell the North
plan were really grown in numbers and
indeed they managed to get hold of the
class I so nothing remains there the
mother is not there the hyena in sight
and there's also not a carcass so as sad
as that may sound
indeed the situation the mother hair-dye
for as long as she absolutely kids but
indeed the situation for now is of
course over so that makes me feel a
little bit better that the mother can
rest shall we say yes that makes me feel
a little bit better so that was my
update on the giraffe situation for now
but other than that I'm just bumblin and
hopefully we will come across something
exciting and the rains due to stay off
I'm absolutely terrified for these rains
that are due to come
not looking forward to driving in them
but you know I didn't even bring my well
either from Scotland I do have a
multicolored selection of welly boots I
didn't bring them so indeed we are going
to bumble on for now and hopefully get
to these lions but you guys are gonna go
back down Society Africa Stevo Jimmy is
up soon
well damn Trishula asked to see some
ostrich in this part of the world not
too common and welcome back Lauren I'm
glad you survived the storm up in East
Africa um we're just moved through quite
a big drainage line and had a lot of
elephant tracks so we're gonna try and
get around and follow up and see if we
have any luck sometimes up on these
crests you get some big trees with some
shade so we'll be moving up to that area
we also had a small antelope down in the
strange land called a bush buck but they
quite elusive we try to stop and see if
we could get it to stick around but they
don't they not very used to camera but
camera shy so sadly we couldn't hold on
to it we back out into the heat yeah and
we should get some big shade on the top
of these these ridges
very interesting out
they'll either the horses the hardest
animal to catch on camera I would say in
this area probably Pangolin some of the
nocturnal stuff so I would say Pangolin
porcupine to to a certain extent and the
Pangolin is that is a scaly anteater and
they're not very nocturnal also quite
very difficult to find but once you find
them they're very slow-moving so they're
not too difficult to follow and if they
sense any danger they'll just roll up
into a ball I've seen a couple of them
and funny enough a few times I've found
them from predators actually finding
them and playing with them so that's the
way if you follow predators they'll
sometimes come across them and roll and
they instinctively roll up and then
they'll they'll play with them and then
you can go in and see what's going on
and that's how you often find Anglin so
it's like the Anglin probably one of the
more difficult things and then also
probably hard to get on form is
sometimes different animals hunting and
and killing because you often down at
night and you don't want to you don't
want to affect the hunt so that would be
very difficult and less that's a diurnal
animal often cheetah
well cheetah will normally always hunt
in daylight hours or all full moon
they've been known to hunt in full moon
so they're a little bit easier to catch
on on camera of hunting leopard a pretty
diverse they'll hunt day and night so
they've been good captures of leopard
hunting in the day so yeah but there's a
lot of stuff that's difficult to get on
a catch on form
births obviously different animals
giving birth especially your smaller
stuff
see how hot that's getting these I'm
just gonna point out something to you
save if you can just shine on onto these
these yeah I'm just gonna show you
it's definitely moisture needed in this
part because you can see these what we
call round leaf ticks and when they
small a very shrubby you can see how
they wilting with the heat and they'll
only really pick up when when we get
some more rain they in this area they
seldom get to be big trees because
elephants absolutely love them it's like
elephant putting these and they get a
nice yellow flower in that's yellow
flower in summer so speaking of
elephants we're gonna continue to find
some elephants but we'll we're gonna
send you to Lauren who apparently has
some for you extremely happy elephants
actually who seems to have been
wallowing and splashing around in some
sort of puddle that I'm not quite able
to see and they are obviously escaping
this very intense mid swells get a not
midday anymore a little bit later than
Minzy but we have a bunch of happy
elephants here and obviously elephants
are highly social animals and indeed
they actually make use of such an array
of communication from smelling
communicating verbally listening
rumbling and all sorts of ways even
touch and we're not aware of and
actually this is one of the things that
most fascinates me nonverbal
communication and this is why I love
looking at animals so much so believe it
or not I actually have a history of sign
language from a child I actually grew up
signing
and no one in my family is deaf but we
grew up signing for the Deaf British
sign language of course unfortunately I
am not familiar with American Sign
Language but let me reintroduce myself
okay you ready for this
and I'm gonna show you exactly what I
mean and why I am telling you this so
this is how I used to speak to deaf
people when we were at home we would
greet each other completely silently so
it would of course be hello how are you
good afternoon my name is Lauren and
this is just fascinated me since I've
been a child hi people and animals can
communicate completely non-verbally and
that's exactly what these elephants are
doing here so we do hear them make noise
'yes we do hear them make rumbles and
grumbles and even trumpets actually
elephants can be very variable and they
can of course be very noisy but they
also have a huge other range of
communications is really hard to get
gripple they can actually communicate
sophistical ii so what that means is the
tip of an elephant's trunk actually has
layers of cells in it that are extremely
sensitive to vibrations so they're
actually able to detect movement of one
another and their surroundings from
those really sensitive cells on the tips
of their trunk and even on the bottom of
their feet so this is another form of
communication that humans can't guess
can just struggle to get their head
around I can definitely struggle to get
my head around that cuz obviously this
is not a capability of humans and it is
just absolutely utterly fascinating I
mean not even that the frequencies that
the elephants can use to communicate
with one another of course some we can
here we can hear very loudly noise of
some sort there but of course they
actually use frequencies that are even
so low for humans to hear they can be as
low as about 12 Hertz
that is completely out of the human
range so this whole hair here could be
communicating to one another and
extremely low-frequency rumbles and
we're just obviously not able to pick it
up and this is indeed have a herd of
elephants is actually able to stay
together and find one another if they do
get lost they're communicating in all
sorts of different ways and just to give
you an indication human males voice
actually fluctuates around 110 hairs so
if you think of a hundred and ten hairs
for human males voice and of course all
meals do some different I am aware of
that
110 hairs I mean you think about an
elephant rumbling it's 12 Hertz that is
incredibly different an incredibly
different range there that humans are
obviously just not capable to imagine
and this is probably what's happening
right here Mariko's asking can an
elephant DJ for what a fantastic
question and honestly I don't 100% know
the answer but I would believe they
could be if they were born if there was
maybe a genetic problem since birth I
believe I guess an elephant could be or
maybe if it damaged its ear in some way
I guess indeed it could be but an animal
like this could survive and thrive
because they have so many other forms of
communication through these vibrations
that are able to detect through touching
through visual as long as they've got
their eyes they can see one another as
long as they've got their trunks they
can touch one another so indeed even if
an elephant was dead I really don't
think it would hinder his life much at
all and this is what fascinates me about
animals humans are so reliant on certain
forms of communication that we forget to
thank animals have so many different
ways of communicating ways that we don't
even think of because humans are so used
to thinking in our very human-like ways
so I don't know of anything else
but I do believe that it's definitely
possible so I will indeed check that out
for sure just what a fascinating topic
and it's just fascinated me since I was
a child how can we communicate
non-verbally and I guess humans do on a
daily base anyway through body language
eye disease facial expressions all sorts
of things that maybe were not even aware
of mmm
lady Starfire get to hear your name do
elephants with missing trunk tips that's
a mouthful have trouble communicating
and no leads on and it goes back to the
fundamental part that we've actually
seen quite a few elephants missing the
tips of their trunk and although they
maybe have to adjust their body posture
or adjust their mannerisms in order to
feed they can still use their trunk
because it's only the tip that isn't
missing so they can still use that in
body language or touching one another
and indeed the soles of the feet do
contain these special cells for
detecting vibrations as well so it's not
just the tip of the trunk so as long as
they can still feet and they can still
drink the trunk will still operate so
indeed I do not think that would affect
them in terms of communication elephants
also have body language that we can even
read we know when we can leave an
elephant alone or possibly when an
elephant is not happy so they can also
read each other's body language and
there's just so many ways that these
fantastic animals can communicate and I
just think elephants in general are
incredible that way and I'm sure there
is more that we don't even know that we
haven't even learned about these
fantastic mammals but indeed they have
such a variety of ways to communicate
that even if say for example one is deaf
or the other one has lost a tip of its
trunk then indeed I really do not think
that would hinder the
it's lifestyle at all what a lovely
sighting they've all just completely got
wet cooled down and they're feeding and
moving at the same time they're actually
all around us we've got some to the
other side as well
Gary's asking do elephants communicate
with other animals that's quite a tricky
question to answer I'm not sure it's
even possible to answer because it's not
possible really for interspecies
communication to work quite like that so
so yes it doesn't work quite like that
because of course if a lion was to
approach these elephants right now they
would indeed reacts and the elephant way
if that makes sense so they would most
likely herd together they would most
likely make themselves so even bigger
than they already do they would trumpet
they will charge their tails we go erect
they would definitely show that they're
not happy the lion or lions are present
but in terms of communicating with the
lion
I do not indeed think that is possible
but they will show their dislike for the
Lions presence and there's many a lot of
footage online where you see elephants
are really shown their dislike of other
animals coming far too close to them so
indeed they would communicate it but in
their own elephant way which I am sure a
lion would probably understand because
it's very visual it's very loud and
indeed these are very big mammals so I
am more than sure that the lion or
whichever other animal it would could be
would indeed get the point and most
likely elephants so very tricky question
Gary but I hope that made sense
obviously between two different species
is not possible to community
like that so I was a lovely lovely topic
to start this afternoon's Drive so why
are we do continue on and I'm gonna keep
thinking about all the nonverbal ways
that animals communicate we are gonna
send you back down to chew shala and her
ostriches yes that it really is
wonderful the way that animals
communicate and elephants especially
because they are absolutely beautiful
and Lauren was telling you about how
they communicate in all sorts of
different ways so even if they are deaf
or something's wrong with them they
still have all these other means of
communication and you know what I'm sure
that humans do too it's just that we're
so focused on language that we forget
now I'm still with these guys
trying to just follow them down and not
too closely they love the way that they
kind of prawns let's watch them as they
walk now now is the time on the right of
your screen is Juma and on the left is a
different reserve so where will you go
back into Juma yes and now I love the
way that they pick up their legs as they
walk is sort of like they're walking on
hot coals very cool you can see those
bare legs they lose a lot of heat from
those bare legs but in this type of
environment that's very useful because
can you imagine carrying around that mop
of feathers oh no chuckles hook now I've
got a question of where I think the
females ostriches are and back again
Claudia you'd like to know where I think
that female ostriches are I have no idea
probably close by I mean they do often
stay in big groups or bigger groups and
at least a pair now they've gone back
into gym I said it just is zigzagging so
the females could be I suppose such a
vast area they could be anywhere really
but we haven't seen Emma on Juma that's
for sure where have you gone where have
you gone they've almost taken me halfway
back oh there you go there you go see
how does eggs egg across
now we were speaking about the water
requirement of them before so I had a
bit of a read and from what I understand
they're not very water dependent so they
can metabolize the moisture out of
things that they eat the nice lush
vegetation but if what is around they
will drink and they will drink as often
as they can I feel like they need a
soundtrack for as they walk away it
really doesn't look like the road is
very hot for them doesn't it
where will you go where will you go with
your tights can't you see the ballerina
look that I spoke about
now if you get a good look at those legs
the thigh muscles look quite
well-developed
ah and they've crossed into the other
side
ah how unfortunate but like I said
they've been zigzagging so maybe they'll
come right back and we said I'm still
telling you about those muscles just as
they walked off and I would have liked
to shown you that they're quite
well-developed ants because they kick
quite a lot as a defense and if you got
kicked by that who you would break
something oh you guys would like to see
the tracks of the ostriches let's go
find some
now we knowing they crossed right ahead
there so let's go find some of those
tracks
and be careful not to drive over them
that's really interesting I'd love to
see the tracks of them too
come on shall I don't drive over them
uh do you see any great I see a few
there
do you see them
very cool actually let me jump off and
have a good look at them
which one have you got inflamed okay
don't want to walk oh wow this is the
first time I've seen something like this
very odd-looking don't you think I know
nothing about ostrich tracks yet but
this is a good example now you see what
a fresh track looks like Craig gave me
this look like there were lions behind
me don't do that like Craig just said to
be ostriches can be quite dangerous on
foot like I said to you that guy had
that attack with the ostrich so ripped
him right through here I think it's very
on track but geez I suppose we can sort
of see you can sort of see the nails or
the claws but it's such an odd track
well tell you why I won't forget this
now if I see an ostrich track I'll know
exactly what it looks like it's gonna
have a look further down
making sure that they're not behind me
very cool well that was ice experience
with you guys this is a very small
footprint there ah there they are
walking in the road let's hop back on
looks looks like they're going for their
walking on their way to an audition
see how what I meant about how there is
zigzagging in and out of humor in and
out ajumma very cool and moving back
into Juma come and guys do it we'd like
to keep you here oh well it seems that
Lauren has found something with a very
long neck also up in the Maasai Mara so
let's go to her indeed we have of course
came across a tower of giraffes which is
indeed quite ironic as we were just
talking about them although most of them
are walking which i think makes it a
journey rather than power and to
continue on the conversation I was
actually asked the other day about the
vocalizations of giraffes and it's funny
that we are just talking about well I'm
just talking about nonverbal
communication because indeed I have
actually learned a lot about giraffes
and it's we deeper than I actually
thought it went so giraffe do tend to be
more on the silent side especially
compared to elephants which we did just
speak about but indeed they were thought
to be so tight-lipped and silent for a
long time and one of the theories was
that they do have a voice box they do
have a Loring's but due to this very
long neck that they weren't able to get
a proper airflow and and make adequate
vocalizations now this myth has been
completely debunked and in fact they do
especially when they're distressed they
will make a very deep bellow
which is a hard thing to listen to but
giraffes really can force out a big
bellow when being born but not only that
believe it or not they are actually
Hummers no I'm not a Hummer myself but
indeed giraffes are said to hum o night
long can you believe that I honestly had
no idea of that either and it's supposed
to be on the very low ends of the
frequency scale now not as long as ell
offense but for the human hearing range
or the human acoustic range it isn't
classified as infrasonic but it's a very
very low aim for the human hearing so
I'm sure humans couldn't really possibly
hear it but of course it's done many
experiments giraffes obviously have
excellent vision and they are the
lighthouses
out here you know they can see for miles
and many other animals rely heavily on
them for clues as to what's going on but
indeed once it gets dark if you think
about it relying heavily on own vision
or visual clues becomes almost difficult
it becomes almost impossible we've just
got some giraffes crossing the roads in
front of us here as well so if they can
sort of rely on their vision anymore
because it's dark then what are they
gonna rely on to communicate and here
you go apparently they hum all
throughout the night to keep in contact
and communicate with one another so it's
not wise enough to attract predators but
indeed the giraffes can communicate with
one another when the vision is
non-existent so isn't that incredible
and it's one of the ways that giraffes
actually are able to stay together in a
sort of loose aggregation like they form
because they can hear each other
it's just humans that cannot incredible
incredible stuff and of course I've spin
ye well the last few days with giraffes
shall I say and it's been very intense
and of course I've just got a newfound
respect for these wonderful wonderful
animals and indeed they're a lot noisier
than you think they are isn't that just
amazing so of course we are owner
emission to get to the Lions but we keep
encountering roadblocks of every shape
and size I didn't catch the name but I
do know I am being asked how do we tell
the age of a giraffe okay let's see if
we can get a little bit closer to this
one at the back boom yay and indeed
Bremen I think is the name you can see
straight away from the genitals this is
male so the males are much larger
sighs than the females and indeed those
sort of patches that they have on their
skin indeed do get darker with age and
their size increases with age and also
of the ossicones on the top of their
head they're not horns they are indeed
ossicones become bolder and bolder and
bolder as the male's age so the best
thing to sort of look at is a
combination of things
coloration size and of course the
ossicones but other than that it's very
difficult to eat a giraffe is very very
difficult and when you see a meal and
female together you would be surprised
at how different in size they actually
are I think this is a female here I'm
gonna be nudge of the male because when
you look at a female you think wow
that's a very big animal but actually
when you found a female next to email
email does tower above her you see what
I did there so indeed it's very
difficult to eat a giraffe but as they
get older the patchi's get darker a meal
or so cones get much bolder and size
comes into play as well so it is a
tricky one but those are the things you
can indeed look for when you are looking
at giraffes so obviously they're all
wandering off into the distance here so
we aren't equal to wander on our mission
as well as fast I have not heard your
name and so long and I remember we had
to get properly taught how to say your
name and dive live a lot of people think
it is Cena but it's not nice to hear
from you now how do you tell if a
giraffe is pregnant I think that was the
question oh I got more traffic nobody
wants to let me go where I'm going to be
indeed swollen belly swollen belly is
what you look at in a giraffe now these
are buffalo so I'm just going to let
them cross because buffalos can indeed
get a little bit cross themselves if you
cross them cross cross cross
so of course giraffes will indeed get a
big swollen belly just like other
animals just like humans and you will
see the mammary glands starting to swell
as well
and that is the best way and the best
thing to look at sits hell if a giraffe
is pregnant but it's not easy
of course even within your big predators
and your big cats it can be really
tricky I remember we were having a
discussion quite some time ago about the
possibility of tansy being pregnant and
it is tricky because especially in the
camps their bellies swell just like mine
do when they eat a lot of food a proper
food calorie and of course that could
easily be mistaken for being pregnant
but normally a cat the belly will swell
but much Lord towards the rear end
rather than a big full and food belly
and of course you will see signs of
preparation for lactation swollen
mammary glands all sorts of things so
what isn't indeed easy but those are the
cues that you can look for now buffaloes
are you going to move out of my wave
possibly not by the looks of things we
are possibly going to blow up loans Road
for as long as possible there we go we
finally have a clear road ahead so while
we get up and go we're gonna send you
back
so Jimmy because he has a bird
Jimmy had a bird there's a pair of them
so we're gonna reposition and a little
bit far but we still have them in sight
I'm not sure if you can see that but
what we have here is a adult and sub
adult better Lea Eagle um you can just
there we are now you can see it's lovely
red beak its preening itself there was I
think I can't see from here but I think
this is an adult owner there was a sub a
dog that just flew off now the sub
adults take about seven years to get to
full plumage and to get to full maturity
this is a it gets its name from the
French word better Lea which means
tightrope walker because it's got a
typical wavy flight in the air it's sort
of dips from side to side slightly it
very seldom flaps because they rely
heavily on thermals and being a lightish
bird with broad wings they probably well
they are one of the first directors up
in the morning
so if their thermals around the battle
ear will be up in the air and they also
known to scavenge and they will often
between Battaglia and tawny Eagles will
often lead you to caucuses and then
later in the day obviously the vultures
will come round come down onto caucuses
because they bigger heavier Birds they
need more thermal
so we'll just such a bit longer to see
if either its mate or the subtitle comes
back and we gonna send you off to trash
Allah there's another Reptar
I am driving but I found something and
he's run away just as I say that let's
see if we can get get a better position
behind us this appear for tongues and
they vanished can you see them K nah
sorry guys we I saw two warthogs just
running along there I quite like them
near where I live we get a lot of
warthogs ones even tried to come into my
lounge before it can be quite funny
especially with you both fries and you
look at each other and you're probably
feeling the exact same thing
slight shock slightly don't want them to
come much closer one hand he's hid
already through with the door and of
course they can be quite dangerous
because they're packing a lot of weight
into that small body you're talking
about 90 kgs from the males into that
into that little body so can you imagine
how solid they are that had to run into
you into your legs they're gonna break
your legs especially with those sharp
tusks as well let's look at these lovely
guys
hello lovely Impala this is a nice
bachelorhood you can see they're all
males with their beautiful horns chewing
away now let's focus on this one is
chewing and there's one scratching
behind him because I didn't see him tuck
his head down so he's probably chewing
some cut which is the partially digested
you know he stopped to talk to me
partially digested food that he would
basically vomits back up but then reach
ooh bit of grooming as well now of
course
they will begin to spy and the rutting
will begin soon again lots of things
going on we've got some eating some
pooping some grooming the days of
Lucian's
really spectacular horns see there's a
female that just came through these are
the few females at the bottom there
there we go now you look at a tongue now
you'll notice that their mouths move
from side to side so they can't really
open their mouths up to chew like we can
and that most carnivores do so that's
one of the things that Oh something
spooked it they look like that elephant
dung spooked it so they chew from side
to side and that's necessary to grind up
all of this vegetation that they eat and
remember that most mammals in fact all
mammals can't digest cellulose on their
own our digestive system just can't
mrs. Lapwing you would like to know with
would they split up during the rut is
that what I heard correctly or not but
during the rutting season the male's
will sort of start to find a little bit
a little bit of territory and that's
when they become too territorial is
during this rutting season they want to
bring as many females into their patch
as possible so now you see the males are
still together so once the rutting
season is in full swing the males will
sort of despise each other for a little
bit now can you see this this little one
here with the horns that are looking
like a horseshoe now this guy is from
about 2017 so the ones if you see ones
that have little buds of horns that are
coming out there from November December
whenever the first lot was born that
just passed so 2018 but these guys here
that have the horseshoe shaped horns
they're probably from the year before in
fact they are from the year before
while these ones do the impressive horns
are fully grown and adults pretty
beautiful I often often think that they
don't get the attention they deserve
because they're so numerous people think
that it doesn't really matter but I
think they're lovely walking around
along on the road very cute anyway it
seems that Lauren is on the search for
some lions I think that's a wonderful
idea I'd like to do that too so I'll be
looking out for treks in the meantime
let's go over to Lauren and see how her
search is going so to kingfishers can
you believe it
and of course dune Robards typically do
they have flown oh oh my first
kingfishers of the Mara and indeed they
did not want to reveal themselves which
is incredibly annoying but we're almost
at the area where the Lions are so we
are gonna continue forward now there's a
bit of a barrier ahead but do not worry
we will get through it her first reading
was that they were beautiful they were
pied kingfishers and there was indeed
two of them now boom back to
communication lions are a very
interesting one and of course we're not
there yet but we are gonna get there and
we are gonna find them because indeed
they communicate in a huge variety of
ways of course mainly when they separate
when males separate or females within a
pride separate they will roar and of
course the roar is one of the loudest of
all the cats and this is due to their
unique biology which indeed allows them
their voice Fox vibrates and it allows
them to obviously roar and call out as
loud as possible and it's said it can
even be heard up to seven kilometres
away if the way there allows for it of
course if there's winds bad weather
other noise then of course the roars
will not be heard but other than not
that is how Lions communicate and we've
even seen
themselves contact calling and doing all
sorts of things hello
that's my communication so in deeds when
lines get separated there were four but
when they're not separated and they're
together they're relying heavily on
olfactory Clues their nose you're our
noses some things forgotten about it out
of all the senses we'll definitely don't
mind I have an extremely sensitive nose
however they will communicate for
example within their urine it will
actually give away a lot of clues about
reproductive states so the male's will
get clues from the females by doing that
famous Flyman grimace by pumping in all
the clues into the palate of the mouth
where there is a special organ that
high-seas chemo receptors and they
obviously receives the chemical clues
and the lion the male lion will know hey
hey this lady is ready or oh this lady
is not ready but in all seriousness the
female has to communicate if she's an e
stris or not otherwise repossess
reproductive efforts will indeed go to
waste what is the point in mating which
takes a lot of effort for lions that
goes on for a long period of time and
indeed it's very frequent it's very
exhausting for them more traffic hello
and Paula so yes what is the point in
going through all that mating process
that whole week of frequent and intense
meeting which exhausted both parties as
the female wasn't ready so the female
leaves clothes and of course it's all in
that sense of smell and it's not just
lions for example lobsters where
everyone seems to think are monogamous I
think Phoebe from friends said that
lobsters are monogamous and that they
hold claws not true
sorry another myth that is being zip
bunked their cereal
monogamous and what does that mean well
the mail will be in his then and again
the female will wait outside and she
will washed her urine into the den until
he accepts it and so he says okay yes
I'm gonna let this lady in she won't go
in otherwise because male lobsters can
be very aggressive and he will look
after her during the time of meeting to
which she will completely malts her
shell so she will be very vulnerable but
he will look after her he will meet with
her and an indeed once it's over and her
shell is reformed she leaves and the
next lady waits outside so again for
lobsters is all to do with the old
factory clues the woman Watson in her
urine and saying hello anybody there I
would like to come in very strangely for
us to think about it but within the
animal kingdom if it can't be hi mr.
lion I'm ready would you like to meet
then how else are they gonna communicate
with one another and one of the main
forms is of course using that sense of
smells is it not incredible so it's not
just on land that's obviously in the
water as well so from Lyons two lobsters
I think we managed to cover quite a bit
of smell here and I like to say hello to
the zebra hi guys
because they are indeed everywhere mixed
in with a few Thomson's gazelles no
Sabra are just a wonderful sight to see
I do enjoy spending time with zebra and
of course these are also animals that do
indeed use the sense of smell to pick up
on clues about what is going on in the
environment and random and they do
indeed to deployment grimace as well
which is hilarious to watch when animals
or humans attempt to do it and of course
they're just trying to understand what's
going on they're trying to perceive
their own environment and indeed animals
will perceive the environment
differently just as humans perceive
things differently and one of my
favorite quotes actually is there
new truth only perception and indeed
that is for each animal will do pick up
clues and the various ways of
communicating to perceive its own
environment and that is how they survive
and sometimes you just have to get into
the head of the animal to actually
understand how an animal does survive
and thrive in its own ecological niche
is that a scratch on that zebras bottom
indeed it is Oh wolf the one on the last
is much worse I think that zebra has
indeed been involved sorry for the
close-up zebra on your sensitive parts
but that wounds on the left leg looks
rather deep and has potentially came
from an animal who has been chasing it
possibly even a lion but that does look
rather painful hmm sorry zebra no
talking of lions we are gonna continue
on our original mission which is indeed
to find those lions that we have indeed
just being talking about now we will get
there once he there just happens to be a
lot of traffic in the form of cars and
many many different animals that all
wants across the road in front of me
so is starting to cool down here for
sure but I'm not sure it's getting any
relief then and juma so we're gonna send
you them to Jimmy to see what he's up to
and
guys no it hasn't cooled down much yet
here but we are just moving into some
thick stuff after a leopard and
and your sons
there we are you can see there we are
we've just moved into this thick stuff
and we believe it's Tandy I haven't seen
definite that I believe it's Tandy I'm
on the move yeah and it's surprising how
she's moving in this heat so we're gonna
try and skirt around maybe and get a
better visual so while we know much are
there you can just see her through these
branches I wonder if he's not seeing
something yeah definitely looking and
listening
you don't want to move at the moment
because we might disrupt what's going on
yeah
very easy money
not this year we've
we had a glimpse of her yesterday in a
very thick drainage line but lost away
quickly so it's nice to be able to catch
up with her again I'm just gonna each
Forge and get a better view
got it
she's moving as if these heard something
way I wonder if she hasn't heard some
Hollow
I think Oh Tonya net
what do you think they've seen something
Hey oh yeah three maybe move around you
we're gonna just get into a better
position and send you over to trash
Allah while we ease into the to the
north of her without trying to disrupt
her oh good luck Jimmy I'm so glad that
there might be if well heal you
hopefully hopefully find as a leopard
again
it's been a really really cool
entertaining day so I thought ah come on
butterflies it's as if they knew they
were going live and then they decide or
fly away so we're here by this little
mud wallow on the side of the road and
we have these butterflies flapping away
you can see that now I'm not a hundred
percent showing an exact species but I
think that the family that they're in is
lai san a day I said that correctly I
think so it's always tough with them
with insects because they seem to be so
many varieties of them now you can see
that these butterflies are moving their
wings up and down up and down and
they'll often do this to catch the Sun
this is at large surface area to absorb
the sunlight in and they'll also do this
to kind of warm up their wings and you
can see that the proboscis is out one of
them I just saw it there you go you can
see that the proboscis is out and it's
searching in amongst those little cracks
for bits of water a really beautiful
looking butterfly
oh this one's got tatty wings
shame poor guy well wouldn't affect his
flight too much
we hope now these wings I have a whole
lot of scales on them and these scales
sort of come off as dust on your fingers
you would have seen when you maybe catch
a butterfly or a moth that this dust
sort of comes off onto your fingers and
those scales provides them with color
and reflection and it's also a really
neat trick because if they fly into a
spider's web while mostly a spider's web
or anything else that's sticky and
uncomfortable they can leave those
scales behind and escape pretty much
unscathed
ah James Richard thank you so much he
said that these butterflies are called
Joker's I can't imagine why suppose
maybe they're funny amongst themselves
very very pretty now I did think that
joke has kind of had little bits of
little ends to their tail I will not to
the tail to the hind wings little bits
that point out but I suppose it's hard
to tell when you don't have them up
close
thank you very much James Richard I was
actually surprised that they were here
where it seems to be quite right for us
this little wallow seems to be quite dry
but to them they obviously can pick up
little miniscule bits of water that's
still trapped in there
remember that in pans like this that
have been dried up all the minerals are
still logged in there so it could be
mineral rich and that's what they're
trying to get out of it as well
very cool and you'll notice that
butterflies when they're at rest will
have both their wings sort of above
their head held high
whereas with moths at rest they'd both
be held down to the ground
very cute
there seems to be something else flying
about there too where did I see it
quite interesting how they all sort of
come together these spots you'd have
seen it with those African vagrants as
well but they all kind of just come
together in this communal spot hang
about or noticed it around water quite a
bit now we're talking about
communication Loren's means speaking
about communication and it comes to
butterflies they also communicate in
quite an interesting way they use
pheromones just like lots of animals do
but they can't kind of leave a pheromone
trail as they go about and if you've
seen two butterflies sort of following
each other through the air it's actually
the one one butterfly the male usually
following a female and smelling her
scent and trying to figure out if she is
ready to mate or not so communication
exists in all kinds of ways it even
happens in colour especially with
insects they communicate well with
colour
GUI you'd like to know how do
butterflies mate
hopefully we'll see no nobody looks like
they're in the mating mode so the way
that they mate is sort of they'll attach
to one another I mean in the usual way
but the male will fly with the female
and it's quite a strange thing to watch
you're sort of like a crane keeps her in
flight with him and he'll fly with her
they sort of bum - bum if that makes
sense
if I see one around I will stop and show
you I've seen a few lately in the last
couple weeks in the last couple weeks
pretty cool I like them thank you James
Richards for identifying exactly which
ones they are
I think they're quite cool so we're
feeling very lucky today Craig and I
always tell him and this car there's no
you and me it's us Craig will do this
we're gonna find some interesting things
so we're still here in the West after
those ostriches I feel a little pumped
yes I do I do
let's see what other exciting unusual
things we might find around the area
that track was quite interesting don't
you think so I have not seen anything
like it now I know that they have those
that really long middle toe but I didn't
expect it to be that long because that
looked really really long but I wonder
if as they walk they kind of kick
forward because lots of animals do do
that as they walk including leopards and
lions as that their tracks can sort of
the sand can be pushed in the front of
them that was really interesting
I see Jimmy has caught up with tandy
good on him he's been doing so well
these last few days so let's go over to
him we've managed to get round to side
of Tandy and Yasmine clintus Sun in her
eyes she seems quite relaxed she's on
the edge of a mound to try and get some
elevation for whatever she's earlier I
still haven't seen anything but she
might have sensed something that we
haven't and she's been moving quite
slowly through this area and we you know
stay with her as long as we can it's a
it gets a little bit more open if she
goes west from here which would she
needs an or that gets a bit thicker I
think so we
definitely listening to something
I think she's also appreciating a better
shade it still hasn't really started
cooling down yet
see the twitch of years occasionally
so they blending in this shaded shaded
light and really dapple Inman dappled
shade is probably where they most
camouflaged
Brendan how that Christian again how
what were letters
letters of leopard cats if array or
leopard sorry um they actually more
common in one things but it's because
they are normally shy and elusive
animals and generally preferring and
being more successful in dense
vegetation thicker vegetation but we
fortunately I mean that we can keep a
track of them because they've they more
habituated but they they they not rare
as in some you know for example a black
leopard that would be I would be closer
justify the black leopard is Ray so
they're not rare but they're not always
easy to find especially in areas that
aren't don't have leopards that or have
that you added to to vehicles or or
someone tracking them for example
see that low blow head she's now looking
below something so she's still looking
out at something
we definitely gonna sit with her for a
better she looks more active than she
was yesterday and send you over to
Lauren with a cat of another kind okay
we have just arrived here to a pride of
lions I'm not a hundred percent who they
are right now but let me just briefly on
what is happening we have a very large
hippo in the distance some of the lions
have been looking at and indeed one
lioness went into food stock mode and
she is currently eyeing up a warthog so
there's lots of things happening this is
a lioness we went into stock mode
now she's going flat on the ground but
it's got a lot cooler here and something
is definitely picking up the interest of
these lions now let us just show you
that hippo right in the background there
there we go it's obviously came out of
the water and started foraging and
indeed to the other side to the far far
right we do have a warthog who is
seemingly unaware that there's a lot of
lions here but acting a little bit
nervous doesn't seem to know they're
here but seems to know that potentially
something is wrong
we've got another lion is looking
they're all steering in the one
direction here and I'm just wondering if
the temperature is getting just right I
don't need to fully be an expert in
visual communication to know that these
dark clouds up ahead are signaling ring
it's now very cool and it seems that the
did you hear that because I was Thunder
okay we've got a lot of a one two three
four of the Lions now is gazing intently
in the direction of the war hold and
indeed there's some Thomson's gazelle
here and some Impala right off in the
distance so that is indeed the direction
that they're facing now we did arrive on
the scene and we were indeed home by the
Ranger that this is B Marsh pride
however there's a lot of confusion
within this area can surrounding this
right now the student needs be the river
pride also now what happens out in the
Mara is it's different organization
sometimes get different animals or
different prides or different clans
different names and it does get a little
bit confusing so I don't want to see
anything just yet until I can properly
ID who these lions are before I make a
confirmation but we've just arrived look
at the Oh gorgeous and they're just
always a family of warthogs it's not
just one more dog I can see
we are is that for I think this is
indeed what is attract and the Lions
attention they've all gone up the
bolstered you know once Lincoln anymore
for yeah there you go
seems to be what they're all staring at
but indeed warthogs are equipped they're
actually very fast and they were quite
but their own weapons stuck in their
height so it's not an easy feat to go
for a warthog you have to be rather
specialized to do that but they're
moving off in the opposite direction
they're too nervous here they know that
indeed something is wrong and of course
all our lions are in front of us right
now and they're a week they do look like
they could potentially get up and move
any moment so we have one two three four
five six seven eight that we can see at
the moment and there are definitely a
lot more alert than we first heard when
we first heard about these lions we got
told very flat cats assumed asleep and I
can assure you these are not flat cats
anymore they are alert one lioness is
watching something off in the distance
here let me just get my BIOS
talking on vision and vision clues I
definitely do need to get my eyes tested
at some point luckily I have binoculars
versus asking about lions reaction to
people in cars now it's such an
interesting question and as my answer
I'm just gonna keep my very own eyes on
these lions because they are indeed
really starting to stir and there I will
come back to it this lioness is moving
forward this is the one whose interest
was initially first piqued and everyone
else seemed to stir after her yeah they
are very interested in something are now
gonna need opposite direction it's aware
that other warthog Ron worked hog get on
my words jumbled up
I'm just watching them all they're
definitely definitely interested in
something and the reason they're not
interested in vehicles or people within
vehicles as they are very accustomed to
vehicles and there's lots and lots of
studies done on this that they don't
recognize humans in vehicles they
recognize the object as a whole so the
whole bring you up to ground oh we've
got some more lines behind us
unfortunately Bunge is not gonna be able
to capture them I don't think because of
the way they are positioned but indeed I
don't oh there you go if this lioness is
walking towards two more right off in
the distance or two
they're all going off on their own
little separate missions here it's gonna
be difficult to keep my eyes on them but
just to wrap up that question yes well
animals especially predators are said to
see the vehicle as a whole
non-threatening of course unless they
are injured by vehicles and of course
they will have a completely different
reaction however they're not able to
identify oh there's three humans sitting
on this vehicle it doesn't work like
that so indeed they don't seem to be
threatened by vehicles there is a
distance limit here in the Mara and of
course we respect that this lioness is
running off somewhere Bungay this one
you see her I can't see what she's going
on we've got Lions right in front of
these lions are hungry I think I can
confirm that much yeah it's the warthog
off in the distance they're going after
the warthog right off in the distance
where I'm probably not gonna be able to
see okay shall we move forward should we
try and move forward we've got lions on
either side don't this may not be
possible unfortunately we've just not
got agreed for you because we have a
lion is about seven meters from the car
right now I can't believe that she got
up and she actually went after a warthog
she's just gone behind that bush now we
just have to be very careful right now
because there we go she's off right into
the distance there she went on our own
little mission alone after that lone
warthog incredible now of course we
cannot drive into the thick vegetation
they are anyway which is fire where she
has disappeared but my predicament was
if we can just see there's a lioness
here and I do not indeed want to drive
and block that lion is his vision and we
have to right here so for me to drive
forward like that wouldn't
be irresponsible as far as I am
concerned so oh we've got a rainbow
nicely spotty Bungay I wonder if we can
capture it for you can you just see the
star of that rainbow there
it's really beautiful where we are in
indeed it goes right over the lions I
wonder in the pot of gold is Wow
incredible
okay so the other lions don't appear to
be moving it just seemed to be one
lioness who did go off on her own little
mission there now we've got other
vehicles appearing and about four lions
behind us so this situation is indeed
becoming more and more interesting
bhaktas asking I think about storms
effect and lions behavior I hope I've
got that right for some reason I'm not
able to understand you know 100% but I
hope that was the question and indeed
weather will affect the animals because
it can actually get predator as an
addict
I think advantage sorry I'm just
watching what's going on I'm trying to
multitask er there's a lot going on
behind me so indeed the Predators can
make use of the fact that it's windy oh
here she comes
look at her coming back okay Shay she
obviously wasn't successful something
piqued her interest but it obviously was
not a successful attempt she's making
her way back towards us and the rest of
the prime so yes predators can actually
use it to their advantage because I've
actually been talking about
communication have an a so it goes back
to that when it's really really windy of
course prey species especially antelopes
will not be able to rely on their
hearing it will also be dark and most of
the prey that Lions go after is indeed
diurnal animals that rely heavily on
visual communication jerseys when it
becomes dark of course they cannot see
these Lions have got the advantage of
having special eyes and special retina
that is adapted to seeing during the
during the night time which the pre
species would not have so if we were
talking about lions they would indeed
you'd use the way they're to their
advantage because pre could potentially
not hear them not see them and not catch
their saints what are you doin girl I am
not 100% sure what indeed this lioness
is up to but she's got bundles of energy
there's another lioness coming out of
the be she's here as well and indeed the
rain is starting to fall not too heavy
yet I really hope it doesn't get that
heavy but it is indeed starting to fall
on us so I do wonder if the Lions are
going to become more and more active so
yes storms will affect the animals but
not necessarily in negative we
animals live out here this is their home
of course they can survive weather
conditions so I do believe we might have
to put our rain covers on very shortly
but we will decide that while we send
you back them to Trish I love looking
for animals yes well in Juma we're not
having very much rain at all
unfortunately but seems like the next
two days might be a bit cooler and maybe
we can expect some rain which would be
lovely for all the animals and for us
really we need a break from this heat so
I am on the western boundary right now
and I like driving this road even though
it is the camera killer Road I like
driving it because it's really
productive and should you do is often
found just walking up and down this road
so always have my eye out for her
sometimes she just pops out and there
she is so considering our good luck with
the ostriches maybe we'll have good luck
which you do do too
it's also much cooler on this road
because the Sun is now on that site so
the shadow of all these bushes are being
cast on us
Nina mu you'd like to know why leopards
are so solitary oh that's sort of the
niche that they have taken if you think
about all the animals that are in sort
of well firstly there's a number of
reasons let me start with this one
all animals full a certain niche within
this ecological environment and there
has to be or they must have been a niche
for animals that are hidden and are
ambush predators as opposed to something
that just runs after things there's
point number one
they fill some sort of ecological niche
that allows them or needs them to be
hidden and solitary secondly they are
everywhere in fact I think the only
environment that they can't survive it
is true desert everywhere else they
pretty much can survive in and also
being solitary means that you can avoid
certain sort of suppose liabilities of
living in a group such as members being
left behind having to look after sick or
tired or
you know injured members
and then also when you're looking for
food you don't have to share it with
anybody now that all fits into the first
point of putting a certain leash so this
they've evolved in a way that meant that
they're their choice or their ability to
be alone has benefited them whereas with
a lion the ability to be in a in a pride
or together has benefited them so it's
very much about what how they've evolved
but I think the most important thing is
the fact that you wouldn't have to share
your meals with any other members and
not have to be concerned with them but
that being said Lions that do hunting in
their in their numbers dogs as well wild
dogs they make a higher percentage of
kills so they're more likely to actually
find food but differences they're going
to have to share that food so that's
quite a loaded question there's a lot of
things to think about why animals
develop in a certain way and it does
have a lot to do with their evolution
so I'm also just looking for tracks Nina
you were asking about you dude
Luna you are asking about Sulu and I
think a scarf but I I cannot really hear
very well it might because I'm on this
end and comes up breaking up just a
little bit for me hopefully Nina would
ah there we go Thank You Nina thank you
for clearing up Luna you'd like to know
what is she do she judo is a female
leopard that's on our property or at
least part of our property and she has
two little Cubs at the moment shadaloo
means termite mound and she was named
after because she's often found on top
of termite mounds
I think that she was born in 2014/15 in
the spring I will double-check that for
you just now but she is a wonderful
Leopard and she has these two little
bundles of joy that seem to be in tow
most of the time we've only seen her
once with the Cubs but other vehicles
and on other properties have seen her as
well so we know that they're well and
healthy and it's just a matter of
finding them up ahead there let's go
have a look we think we have spotted
something on the road let's see
also keeping an eye out for tracks but
the problem with a road like this is
it's because it's so so well driven on
tracks can often be obliterated quite
easily
I also need to keep an eye up into the
trees and we'll see what we find
ah I see up ahead okay so while we get
into great an investor position it's not
shedule it seems to be a little baby le
let's go to Jimmy to give you a bit of
an update on Tandy we've just cut around
to a little track and she spool was
moving she stetic Indiana adjuster don't
run an Impala talk to our um John North
so we gonna go back and see if she moves
in front of us
saying them I think not whether they
sure they picked up on her scent or not
or
there is okay what do we got there
yeah I think she's yeah she's coming
straight towards us yeah so I'm gonna
move back a bit and she should cross in
front of us yeah
she's the lights not
Kota yes here we go
she definitely she definitely heard that
Impala park in see her she's not trying
to pinpoint the position of them
beautiful there we go
see those years a nice pendant trying to
find their position of these importer
and see
beautiful posture typical cat posture
there
it's nothing the era but you see that
he'd raise slightly
somebody good question now we don't have
black leopards in this area but up
towards the Drakensberg mountains
they've been records very few records
birth records nevertheless of black
leopard at them on the in the high fault
region of the Drakensberg but in the in
this province and but certainly not
common at all
yeah
and I stay as long as we can with her
and send you send you over to Lauren
with those lions she has
relaxing cat
okay the situation remains we've got two
lioness who had just spotted the
warthogs I think it is the same family
walking directly towards them I can feel
the tension it's in the air one lioness
is very visible on the mound so she's
just frozen watching them but one
lioness spotty dumb and she's actually
gone in to the vegetation to begin her
stalking so we've tried to position
ourselves to get a few of everything
because these lionesses are hungry and
they're up to something and one of them
was very focused on this war hawk family
I feel like they were not entirely too
sure I don't know where that lionesses
that went off into the thicket she's
there she's watching them but I think
she needed them to come a little bit
closer and they're not so this is a
visible one look at that body posture
communication right within itself there
you can tell this lion is trying not to
move not to attract any tension she's
got a body law to the ground but she's
allowed she's watching these warthogs
very very intently I just can't see
where the other lie in his way
okay the Warhawks are moving closer I
don't think they're aware they're
walking into lions I really don't know
this lion is on the mind must stay still
because the warthogs are nervous but
they are indeed walking right in the
direction of all of these lions now
they're very separated so he honestly
don't know what's gonna happen here I
want the warthogs to get a little bit
closer
see how cautious they are they're really
not sure and I don't know what it is
that's making them unsure but they
definitely haven't spotted the Lions now
those lions in free rare to my life and
to my right and there is indeed hmm yep
the warthogs are walking closer they're
walking right towards that lioness
right towards her now lions are master
stalkers but indeed it's all about the
timing and it's all about getting it
right and making sure the pre is within
the correct distance so this is risky a
warthog would be a perfect snack but the
lioness has got to get it right now
they're very very interested whether
they're actually gonna go for these
warthogs or not I'm really not sure but
I can tell you oh ok they've changed
direction they have completely changed
their direction and they're walking off
look at that they're skipping off I
wonder if they knew something was wrong
you can see the young just trying to
keep up with the adults there that was
so close
Jessica's askin are these lions likely
I've got my rain covers on by the way
likely to go after the baby warthogs and
indeed that is the most tricky thing now
I'm just keeping my eyes on this lioness
here because that is the one that was
having a look and Jessica indeed I'm not
sure they've been watching these
warthogs very intently in full
stalk mode for quite some time now
now lioness can also hunt on their own
they don't need their pride I'm just
gonna be positioned in the car here if
they wish they can indeed hunt on their
own and maybe that's exactly what that
lioness was planning on doing maybe she
was just hungry and she saw a perfect
opportunity so there we go we've got all
these lions in front of us I'm just
gonna go forward a bit so Jessica I
don't know but they were definitely
stalking without a word of attack and
they're definitely hungry so indeed if a
warthog presented itself I don't see why
the lioness would not take that
opportunity if the opportunity was
indeed the right one now all the lioness
are in front of us right now we've got
more coming in from the left so we don't
lose sight of them because they're
definitely all up to something and again
this is a perfect example that would
have been talking about they're
constantly in visual reach with one
another they constantly keep looking at
one another if not made any sounds I
haven't heard any variable communication
but these pride members one looks a bit
stiff doesn't it it's a bit of a stiff
walk yeah but they're remaining within
visual distance of one another they know
exactly where each other are and indeed
they pick up on each other's cues if you
like so when one lioness does get hungry
and something piques our interest the
other lion is pain to follow suits
Joy's asking a question that I know I
should be able to answer but right now I
probably can how many Lions have we
spotty now I saw at least tame but we
keep seeing more coming in and this is
what is confusing me so right now in
front of us we do have seven but they
were definitely eat there definitely was
more than that so again I haven't
confirmed which pride this is definitely
not the only low lows for sure but
within this Marsh pride and river pride
confusion I am really not sure and I'm
the Ranger did see the marsh pride but I
do feel this is the river pride but
before we make any confirmation on these
lions are I do need to do some more
investigation I just can't take my eyes
of them right now in to the deep
vegetation where we will lose sight of
them I really hope they don't but
they're definitely on a mission
somewhere you know lioness can get very
stressed when they're separated so they
will sometimes wander off lioness are
known to go off with meals for example
and sort of lose sight of their pride
and when they rejoin in their pride they
will Quang sacs called use a lot of
calling to find one another and indeed
lioness can we often hunt on their own
they can they are strong enough and worn
and capable enough to do that
and whether they would go after a
warthog indeed with present on the
situation itself now a warthog and adult
warthog does indeed contain a lot of
meat it would be the perfect snack for a
lioness if she was on her own no I see
snack but of course
warthogs are not an easy prey to catch
now some of our leopards than in Juma
are obviously experts at it but warthogs
could indeed really harm a lion eh so
I'm really not sure I should indeed Oh
for that I think those lioness were
hoping that the warthogs would walk
right towards them but indeed they
didn't they changed their direction
otherwise I do think that lion a spoon
to have went for one of the warthogs
same thing what is going on around them
and the Thunder is rumbling and the dark
clouds are indeed cooling and so bad
where there is on its weak eye of course
I'm prepared with my rain covers the
drizzling has stopped so we didn't need
to be the rain covers on the vehicle but
just in case so the weather is changing
and the Lions are probably very much
picking up on it and maybe that is what
is waiting name up now that was a tense
situation watching the warthogs get
closer and closer and obviously they
made the right decision - indeed but
where we are right now is very close to
catch what airstrip and it is indeed
where boo sorrow was residing for quite
some time now interestingly enough after
the Ola Lulu and River prized clash
which was with Patrick and it was a very
hard sighting for everyone to watch boo
Sarah has since no insight it's insane
and it is my firm belief that she has
indeed gone far away from all the Lions
and all that commotion but another lion
is coming to join the others they do
like to be close to one another Lions
they do enjoy being social and they do
enjoy contacts with one another
especially lions with Anna pride that is
one beautiful
look at the spots on the underbelly and
the legs stunning
so the Ola laws and the river pride
territories meet
so obviously territories are fluid but
indeed the sort of boundaries of these
two prides do clash and that is indeed
what happened the other day so my
feeling is that this is indeed the river
pride but I will check up on that right
now and get back to you so indeed I am
not the only one looking for spots I
have my spots in the form of lions but
Trishula is still looking for hers
I have also got some spots so my search
for shoe doodoo has turned up nothing at
all but I made my way back down and I
found myself at the hyena den you know
it's like a magnet it just pulls me in
so it is fairly active at the moment
we've got two adults around we've got
ribbon who you're looking at right there
you can see the Nick in here yeah hey
ribbon girl passed out she didn't lift
her head when we came in and we've also
got the big she is hey Corky also
knocked out flattened there we've got
one of pretties cubs looking quite big I
must say nice fluffy Jamie's always told
us that they go through a phase where
they get really really fluffy when they
kind of just coming out of cub hood
almost all the normal very protective
stages where they're still hanging about
by the den all the time and this is kind
of why pretties comes out at the moment
because they're mooching about all over
the place I saw them crossing the road
the other day in the evening so they've
definitely grown a lot
so shaggy and so sleepy it's a very
sleepy day I'll change human
now cookies around so I wonder where
plunky is she's showing us a nice view
of those pads of her feet so you can see
exactly where those tracks come from you
can see that the each toe the nice and
kidney shape those toes kind of like
puzzle pieces as opposed to little round
dots like the leopard and you can see
the two lobes on the pad also unlike the
leopard also see the little nails coming
off punky do you need a spa day
bring in a really interesting question
there you'd like to know what the
laughing means for hyenas now you'd be
probably familiar with the fact that
hyenas Dula for some of them at some
point in their life will be laughing
away for example Koki here does not do a
lot a lot of laughing because laughing
is something that indicates nervousness
or sub ordnance almost and you'll find
that very nervous hyenas or the hyenas
are very low ranking when they approach
other high-ranking hyenas especially a
time at a kill they'll start to giggle
this sort of maniac 'el kind of cackle
oh they go around hello and that sort of
giggle indicates being nervous and
unsure and wanting to be submissive to
the other
hyenas around it so it's not the typical
sound the typical sound is of course the
whoop mmm goes something like that
I've even heard these little guys doing
a mini whoop good it's the cutest thing
you'll often hear them squid ring which
sounds like kind of like your puppy does
and I didn't actually hear them do the
little whoop before but then I heard it
I thought that is the cutest thing fast
asleep but you'll notice that they're
never quite totally asleep well I can't
speak for ribbon here who looks
absolutely knocked out I mean ribbon
hasn't budged so if you see her nose
dripping there it is oh it's a proper
truly sleep Luna you'd like to know if
ribbon is low-ranking well it's sort of
difficult to sort out rank below
Maitreya now we know for sure that
cookie is matriarch and we do know that
I think it was pretty used to be quite
high-ranking but then suddenly it fell
now you'd be able to tell by the
interactions with each other just how
high-ranking they are and now Koki sort
of overthrew the previous matriarch
which was I think madam and pretty which
caliph whose cub is around you above
Corki there we go that's pretty scab
pretty was actually the daughter of
madam or possibly most likely the
daughter of Madame so she would have
been next in line if that makes sense
and she used to kind of be very
high-ranking but then something happened
and she dropped in her rank and I miss
we dropped in her rank that's something
that you can see quite easily when they
interact and you can see who lifts up
their their leg first for the greeting
who's
head is down in a submissive kind of way
and as for ribbon who we are speaking
about she has kind of always just been
Oh lifting up your head
Ruben you're also steer stirring she has
always kind of been in the middle from
what I can gather
I didn't don't imagine that she was if a
very high ranking but the fact that she
is gaining here with June and her cubs
means that possibly they're on the same
level
but when Corky comes into the show and
thrown into the mix it is no there's no
doubt at all about her status
flop back down
hey cookie cookies gonna bid alert I
think she can hear a vehicle going by
and she's just lifted up ahead
okay cool look at the two of them it's
like mini-me
next to each other both with the ears up
both ears moving side to side listening
around very very cute ah there seems to
be someone else coming in and now if
they are Cubs around which they are
there's someone else coming in then I
will move off and give them an
opportunity to view them as well so
while I do that why don't I send you
over to Jimmy to give you a small update
on what tndi has been doing we've
managed to stay with her and actually
nearly lost us in this thick stuff now
if you can see it's pretty much all you
can see is a little white tip of her
tail
she's definitely heard something to the
north of her to our left and we're gonna
try and get a little bit closer but I
don't want I wanna try and get parallel
to her
maybe we got
he's having
yes seem to be moving in both directions
we had delivered a hyena that was
following her a little while ago but
seems to have moved off so she's more
relaxed now but in heaven it seems to be
having a short rest but certainly alert
nonetheless
is that amazing
camouflaging this brown grass
taking that Vantage of
I mean arrest before she moves into
action again
I have seen shoe duel and a while ago
and yes I've haven't seen haven't seen
she do the often but I have seen I have
seen she really yes
delivered
the Leopards in lawn lousy that I was
most familiar with was the leopard which
we called the old mother so she was one
of the first habituated leopards at
London Ozzy and then she had a had a
female trap called the two one female
which were acquainted a big drainage dry
riverbed south of her position and she
was a lot bigger than her mother and had
quite a temperament quite an aggressive
female although would allow you in her
space but she certainly let you know
that he will close enough a bit like a
bit like this female and but she seemed
to be a bit bigger than then Tandy
I think she's really probably taking
advantage of the light dropping now um
because that will benefit her more as it
gets a bit darker she's been hearing
quite a lot I mean she'd be with she was
found in the heat of the day moving so
she's moved quite a distance in the heat
so she's certainly making their most of
this temperature cooling down now
now she stays alert even though she's
looks like she's sleeping her his senses
are always ready to be pricked up and
that's obviously how they survive in
these environments who has hyena that's
what she heard hyenas just sneaked in
and has picked up her scent in fact it's
a hyena coming to our from our right
towards her there we go
so there we go you can see well she
picked that up long before I heard
anything
um so watch the watch this watch this
this is fun phenomenal she's probably
gonna give it a bit of a charge and then
- off
I would imagine look at her tail when
the guy in has even seen her
must have seen I can't believe this
he hasn't seen it he's heard it
something but he hasn't he's gonna walk
straight but they literally 2 meters
apart if he starts moving away she will
just why no because she doesn't want to
attract his attention back quite a big
female this father looks at it she
taking
you see
back resting again
from absolute alertness and tension - to
slumber
well let's wait for the next tie you
know what's that was some interesting
behavior and action
yep
well we definitely gonna sit around with
her and while we do that and she takes a
nap we were gonna send you to Lauren in
the Masai Mara Oh Tandy and her
beautiful smile I do miss her but most
of all I miss Corki please do tell my
quarks I miss her now the lion saga is
just continuing lionesses are coming out
of everywhere and of course we are
losing light very fast didn't have much
of a sunset tonight because of all the
clouds but indeed we have on own two IR
infrared because we are losing light and
we want to keep track of all these Lions
because indeed they're all up to
something
now the warthogs did a huge loop a
ginormous loop all the way runs and they
have indeed disappeared into the bushes
but the lionesses interest was still
very much Pete there's two lioness that
appear very skinny shall we see on the
hungry side and they're definitely
definitely interested in something but
me being a human and inadequate I indeed
cannot pick up what it is I do not happy
the lion or the eyesight of a lion but
some oh is that the warthogs ahead yes
it is it is okay the warthogs are up
ahead now they're far off but what these
lioness have done I've actually gone
into the thicket hoping that the
warthogs are gonna come back round I
think and now we just have the most
terrible view of all let's just wait and
see where this little family of warthogs
go
if they decide to go around then they
could be in some trouble right in that
bush that you can just see - your life
is a whole gang of lions let's just wait
and see if the warthogs pass through
here
the camera can definitely pick up more
than I can right now they're in there
they're weeding the warthogs for some
reason want to continue on their
original plan okay so we've got more
lioness on the move here and they're all
heading towards this one bush
it's all happening inside this thicket
we know it's not the perfect view but we
are a little bit far and we are using
our infrared light this is the perfect
time the perfect temperature for the
Lions indeed to get up it's cooler it's
getting darker their advantage of having
that special layer in there I called the
tepee tone lucidum which double backs
the reflection of light so they get it
twice on their retina and it obviously
helps them sleep much better in the
night many nocturnal animals have this
even including sharks in the ocean it is
not just a land-based thing they're all
making the way in towards this fish
which is so unfortunate for us because
of course we cannot drive into the bush
I would if I could
however I feel these ladies and there
are a few sub adult males are going to
hunt it is hunting time
she's awfully are you going girl can you
hear that
okay they've all run off in the one
direction I can hear lots of
vocalizations and unfortunately my
vision is the bish there's definitely
something going on right now and
unfortunately we are not able to get any
closer what shall we do I think we're
gonna wait it out there's a warthog have
frustrating if only we could see exactly
what was going on in front of us but all
these lions are after something I think
I'm just gonna stay put here for now
maybe go a little bit further forward
and indeed I think the Lions will come
back with something but let me just go a
little bit further forward although it
doesn't seek us any closer I'm afraid
but possibly we can get a better view
this way of what these liens are and
deep up to
oh it's so difficult to see I do not
have nocturnal eyes
but I think they chased the Warthog or
at least one of them
no the land is very marshy here because
of all the rain
can't be anything just yet
you see anything bengay okay something's
happening and it always happens just as
we're losing light you know let's just
take a scan and see if we can see
anything
we'll use the camera of course because
that's way more equipped for it than I
am
anything at all
Lyons where did you go indeed they have
disappeared all of those lions how on
earth can you just disappear from us
like that that is incredible of course
they've obviously gone into the bushes
and I really do think they were chasing
Riya
okay that indeed does look like a very
relaxed lioness one that is indeed not
hunting or stalking there you go
everyone else seems tough disappeared
but we do have one lioness rolling
around in the grass which was not what I
expected here we go here's a one so you
can just see by that body language off
into the bushes this lioness is indeed
on a mission of some sort we just have
no idea what that is so while we try and
figure all of this out let's send you
back down to Miss Tandy herself
we've stuck with her and followed her
back towards a drainage line and luckily
for us she took up into this marula tree
seems to be resting in this marula now
and so it's gonna be worth sticking with
her she's definitely got up here to see
if there was to get me elevation and
watch she was looking at as we got
closer to her she's seems to be having
another snooze in the tree for now so
we're gonna reposition so he can maybe
get a bit more of a bit more than of a
bitter angle on her so just stay with us
folks while we move and then horse if
she comes down we might be in a better
position for her when she comes down
oh yeah yeah yeah hey we got it just
looks pretty good from yet
good here we go sip my side on of her in
the tree you are for the other ones
either eyes are open or closed from here
no seem closed so he's having a little
nap up in the tree now
beautiful is about and show you how
stunning is that no it's absolutely nice
a vestal sky behind her and I think if
she comes down we might be in quite a
good position to get her side on um
hopefully not behind the tree she's
heard something again I wonder if it's
not another hyena sense it's just always
on to
you know that was around earlier ran off
or moved off steadily and sort of gave
up and I think he even saw her typical
leopard toys
Lisa certainly does look comfortable
she's found a fantastic perch up in this
marula and I think he can get better
than that supporting her back legs and
the beautiful horizontal branch for her
there's a nice wide shine you the
terrain Wien there's typical marula like
marula woodland and then she's luckily
moved down over the thickest stuff and
so we managed to stay with her
fortunately
um territorial lipids territorial as
lines most definitely the leopard
females and males will mark territory so
what normally happens is a male might
have depending on area which areas the
hidden might have three and three to
four females within its territory so he
has to control that area to keep other
males coming in to its area and land do
the same so the male the male lines
would do the same with prides and male
alliance would often keep territory for
one two sometimes three different prides
so it's a similar behavior but on a much
larger scale four lines leopard
territories the females would mark an
area and in in this low felt region they
have approximately a fifty square
kilometer territory and males up to 90
square kilometer territory where's the
lines sorry the male leopard ninety
square kilometers where's the lion could
cover big my alliance could cover a
couple of hundred square kilometers that
they'd have to control and and dominate
over
and how they would how they would
control that territory is by moving on
its boundaries and marking with urine
scratching the ground spreading the
scent on its feet and and transmitting
the scent wider than just the the urine
patch and often they would keep their
tail up and urinate onto bushes and both
leopard and lion to do that and then
also vocal so they would roar to keep
nomadic males out of their territory and
so they vocal and scent
yeah they
the last Birds starting to settle down
there's a few birds in the background
calling gently sitting down for the
evening might be lucky enough to get
taught our calling
she looks pretty settled for now we're
gonna see what Lauren is up to with
those lines you might have a bit more
action than we do right now so I will
send you to learned indeed ever Alliance
they just appeared just out of our reach
they were on a mission what interest in
behavior we have indeed watched tonight
this is a very cohesive site and that is
of course what price are all about but
they were very much working together
they are on some sort of mission which
means that failed to figure out what it
was but that was the wonderful
interaction and of course Jimmy was just
telling you about leopards and their
sort of territorial behavior with lions
and although both leopards and lions are
very closely related
they're both Panthera and deep there's
sort of lifestyle their spatial tactics
and their social tactics are very
different I think
mashaallah mentioned earlier that
leopards are solitary they spend their
life completely alone unless meeting of
course
and unless happen Cubs they're solitary
animals solitary cats so they have to
communicate in a completely different
way
than lions would when their social so
they have the same fundamental ways of
communicating but their behavior is
going to be very different for a male
lion just changing my gears there for a
male lion we will indeed spend time with
a price that is resets it to him and
they both spent time in a coalition you
have to remember that a leopard with my
gearbox here tonight are on their own
so even although it is the same
fundamental behaviors between the cat
olfactory cues scent-marking
calling kangana sauce lion's roar
obviously they completely have different
lifestyles and I just think that's
indeed very very fascinating leopards
territories females and males and deep
overlap and obviously for lions out here
is completely different social behaviour
they are far more social they're said to
be the only social cat out here in
Africa because they do have these
cohesive price and of course I think you
can use the word cohesive for the
coalition's as well actually the males
are quite they can be actually very
tender and their social bonds with one
another and coalition's do separate they
do come back together again but
essentially they work together they
socialize and they can even hunt and
kill
there's completely different behaviors
which i think is indeed very very
fascinating now we are just making our
way out of this area and the lightning
and the Thunder is continuing on to the
side of us here right above our camp so
I'm not sure our journey home is going
to be an enjoyable one however for the
time being we are indeed dry what an
afternoon it has been from elephants
Citra to lions all talking about
communication along the way and indeed
of course I am fascinated with
communication in the ocean as well and
indeed it's a whole different medium
being suspended in water how on earth do
you communicate now I believe it or not
fish can actually make a huge array of
sound even more than some vertebrates
and mammals I hear and they do say that
hearing that first come from the water
that is one of the theories and of
course fish may appear silent but indeed
they are not Maya has to remember that
sound travels five times faster in the
water so I think it's effective to say
that fish do use their hearing a lot
more than you think they would now I'm
just going to get out of this area that
we are in which could be a bit tricky so
why don't we do that we will send you
back then to Charlotte
yes well speaking of hearing there's a
lots of animals around here that have
great great hearing and you can see it
from the size of the massive ears like a
kudu who does have these huge ears and
the wild dogs ears those are really
really striking so you can sell it
hearing is such a great advantage of
course there's some animals that you can
barely see ears and they kind of have
just little holes and they're signs of
their heads like reptiles like lizards
they have those type of inner ears and
not not much else externally but
speaking of reptiles I'll tell you my
fun fact for the day on this day in 1989
a hundred and fifty million year old
dinosaur egg was discovered and that was
really important because for a long time
there had been a gap in the fossil
record in that hundred hundred millennia
sort of section so that was the first
time that they had found a dinosaur egg
with an embryo still inside it and I
think that's really cool so on this day
it was published in science so that's a
journal on the 31st of March in 1989 and
that's sort of egg that a reptile would
produce well they called amniotes which
is basically basically most of us it's
mammals reptiles and birds produced a
kind of egg with separate little bits
and it has different parts to it you
have the
amnion which is the actual liquid that
the fetus sits in and that's an
adaptation from being in the sea for a
long time or things having evolved from
creatures in the sea because it was so
important that that fetus wouldn't dry
out so then that adaptation became quite
important to have that body of water in
you now science the amnion and then you
also have the chorion which it's the
part of the egg where gas exchange
happens and that's a really cool part in
a hyena because in a hyena that is very
similar to our own and that's part of
the placenta that does gas exchanging in
the hyena it's very very similar to our
own and sometimes I wonder if that
there's sort of robustness when they're
born is a result of having that really
thin layer so lots of gas can be
exchanged between the momma and the
fetus there's also the land toys said in
a strange way I might have said it
incorrectly but in shorts in Atlantis
and that is the part of the egg where
waste gets taken away or stored and with
reptile that's usually stored in the
form of uric acid and that's because if
it's stored as urine like it is within
us then they're wasting water that they
could have used in other ways so they
actually store it as little crystals of
uric acid which I find really cool and
then of course you have the yolk sac and
the yolk sac is where the fetus is
getting all of its nutrients from so
there you go dinosaur egg 150 million
years ago and now you know all the parts
of the egg - I think it's quite cool
it's amazing how we find these things
and kind of puts you in your place it
makes you remember the fact that it's
not just us
on the planet and it hasn't been just us
that have been dominant on the planet
there's there was a time where we
weren't sharing everything was working
perfectly well it's always nice to
remember that
well it seems like for the little but
more off the show we have left I'm gonna
try the hyena den one more time because
I did find the other vehicle has left so
now we can go back and join it hopefully
they won't be so sleepy so in the
meantime while I make my way there let
us send you over to Jimmy and see what
Tandy is up to well folks not much has
changed what has changed if we switched
from daylight to a very special camera
called an infrared camera and as you can
see it's got gray tones and it's a
little bit more grainy but it gives us
the advantage of viewing these animals
in darker conditions without affecting
them with bright lights on them so it's
a quite a artistic effect and it really
does give us an advantage of doing these
nocturnal and while these animals that
are active at night and it's it's really
a special camera and helps in enormous
li in these conditions without it you
wouldn't see it at all without shining
lights on here so it's fantastic
advantage for us and you can see the the
tones now that Sabres pulled back you
can see how the sky's got this beautiful
pale blue gray effect and the the greys
and dark colors of the tree and leaves
and it's actually very special to you to
be able to see the effect of these
cameras but he's slumbering on and
hasn't moved much too tall while you've
been and up in the Mara and we're gonna
just sit around for a little bit longer
and I think she's gonna do much but will
sit here for a little bit longer
no hyena
rocked in yeah while or we've been
sitting within a tree
giraffe both my most memorable sighting
of a leopard I'll have to think of it
about that but I would say seeing a
female leopard in a rocky outcrop den
with her cub and so she was at the
entrance to her being a rocky outcrop
and she was sitting at the entrance and
the cub was just visual behind her to
the side of her and I would say that was
very special but I've been fortunate in
having a number of memorable sightings
of leopard and obviously the the action
one's always good and you know hoisting
kills up trees interaction with hyena is
always special and and just watching
them on on the move and the hunting
behavior their stealthy their patience
is the patience is phenomenal and and so
and yeah and big males you know moving
close to you you really get a sense of
the power of these these animals so I've
had a number of wonderful experiences
were these cats and but leopard and
chubs is always very special
well I think we're going to I don't
think she's gonna do too much we might
leave her shortly and let her slumber on
and see if we can follow up on her
tomorrow or if someone can follow up on
her tomorrow and see whether she's had
any success in the in the night and I
think she certainly was looking for
something earlier so I would imagine she
might hunt on into the night oh bit of a
movement this could be bit and if she
it's done to the next folk we might get
it coming down the tree there we got
have a bit of a stretch there maybe not
yeah
down the hopefully down the right slip
of the tree not come on some of the side
go yeah
mocking she just marked against the
triode and if you saw that she had a
tail that up and she actually marked
against that tree before she moved off
so she disappears into that tall grass
you can
hardly pick up neveress yeah but if
there's a little Harsanyi see the dark
patches bandha yes that's where you can
release the of it now she disappears
into the night are we gonna move back to
the road and I don't want to follow her
through here too much because I'm only
gonna hit some logs and make huge noise
for she is hunting
there will be heading off to the road
try and find a road and leave you to
Lauren in the Mara with some apparently
some storms building I get into get
I feel any moment now we're gonna get
swallowed by the storm that's rolling in
this sky is electric it is dark it is
illness and it's gonna be some night
ahead I can only hope we make it back
safely in time before the absolute time
for that is on its way makes it to us
but for now we did try to give you a
view of the light night but it's been
very sporadic all of a sudden and we're
not wait
management's getting a perfect view for
you but I can assure you it is
absolutely electric
right now not as cold as I thought it
would be but the minute this rain comes
it is gonna get a lot more chillier oh I
hope you aren't getting a few of the
Lightning flashing off in the distance
there we're just weakened are we through
another gate at the moment but before I
do get swallowed up by the storm and is
obviously worth concluding our wonderful
topic of communication today well-known
verbal communication at least and of
course we rely heavily on all of our
expenses for that and I'm gonna get my
spotlight out so I can actually see now
one thing that fascinates me is as a
child you are taught you have five
senses eyes nose mouth and touch but the
more I've read the more I've actually
looked into this I'm not sure that's
actually quite accurate is it and I'd
love to hear your thoughts I'd love to
hear if you do agree with me what about
the sense of pain that guides us through
life and warns us not to go into
dangerous situations for example put in
your hand on a very hot stove what about
your sense of balance some people
actually have a terrible sense of
violence all due to that inner ear or
the sense of gravity all these different
senses that we do use on a daily basis
they're not actually included in our
senses and of course these are indeed
what help us navigate and communicate
through our daily
oh so I don't know if you will agree
with me and I'd love love love to hear
your thoughts more than happy for you to
disagree with me if you do think that we
do indeed have more than our five senses
that we regularly talk about on a daily
basis now of course both sides are the
fundamental senses that we do use to
communicate prefer to communicate in
different ways from others some are much
more or ovae's some are more auras
auditory based it's completely different
and then when you come to the world of
animals you've got to think of electro
reception
what about seismic communication what
about Turtles who actually use tectonic
plates to navigate what about I'm lost
there I thought I saw something just
open its head up on the grass there but
it's very difficult to see
yeah what about all these chemo
reception electroreception all these
different way that animals especially
even in the ocean communicate and
navigate sharks can feel electrical
impulses and they can actually detect
vibration that is definitely something
that is hard for us humans to envision
because we can't do that it is so out of
our box that we contain ourself and so I
have been informed many of you agree
with me about the same so pain the sense
of balance and all these other senses
that we do forget about I'm glad to hear
it
that feeling yes that other sense that
we probably do not speak about often so
although we are making our way through
the storm and probably not doing a great
job of it mashaallah that's my favorite
animal yes I found myself a friend here
this is one of pretties cubs it's grown
so much look how tall it is very very
sweet always when I come here these two
pretties - and plunk must come to the
car to say hello always and I love it I
do love it and when I have to stay you
say to them stop it stop it I half don't
want them to stop but they need to stop
of course before they start chomping on
tires look at look at how grown it is
and the shape of the back it's just so
like so like an adult
monie you'd like to know if the
submissive hyenas if they afraid when
the when the matriarch is around I think
that is what I heard and in general
there is a certain pecking order there
is a certain pecking order and when you
see the lower ranked hyenas come through
and they go to Cokie there's an
immediate reaction and you can see
exactly who's who's submissive or
low-ranking and exactly who is
high-ranking it's actually so obvious
even at or especially at a kill because
a low-ranking hyena might only get about
nine and about 2 kgs of
food from a kill whereas a
higher-ranking hyena like cookie would
get as much as 18 kgs if she decides to
gorge herself but an average she would
get something like 9 kgs so it is really
really obvious and if you say scared
Monique I'm sure there is an element of
fear as in you don't want to sort of
make the matriarch angry with you
because if she is then she might just
decide that she's had enough and she
wants to get rid of you and if she
decides that and you can't fight back
then you have a problem
nina has just had told me if they asked
me if they feel safer when the patriarch
is around or the high-ranking a hyena is
around well I suppose there's a bit of
both I often think of hyena social
structure or hierarchy a lot like the
Mafia if that makes sense so although
there is a top dog and he will take care
of you or she will in this case she will
take care of you no matter what and you
are part of her clan you are slightly in
fear and that she might just snap at you
but then at the same time she is also
protecting you so it's a bit of a
catch-22 and you want to make sure that
you are always on the right page and
here you Cokie wants to me oh well the
subordinate females want to make sure
that Cokie knows that she's totally
totally respected and that unless they
decided to overthrow her they better toe
the line and you will see it clearly
when Cokie is around and the other
hyenas come through very very clear in
fact maybe next Drive will be lucky
enough to be able to see that there's
been lots of activity around you and
lots of hyenas coming through and the
greeting ceremonies quite suspect
and you can see exactly who's who it's a
really nice little scenario to watch how
everybody fits in well it's been an
awesome Drive and this little cubby says
goodnight as he goes back into the dim
yes and of course thank you so much for
your questions and comments we always
love having you guys on board and we'll
see you in the morning for the sunrise
Safari